[Music]
my name is and welcome to I'm standing
outside in the garage thing and I feel
like everyone's watching me so it's kind
of awkward first stuff I want to say we
did it bros again I think it was three
months ago we had 1 million subscribers
and now I was already a 2 million I'm
like I don't know it's crazy it's crazy
how fast it went I never expected it to
go that fast honestly I thought ok we
hit 1 million but it's probably gonna
stop now but a lot of things happened
you bros kept coming in nevertheless I
want to say from the bottom of my heart
thank you both for two minutes
subscribers it's way more than I ever
imagined and I can I usually imagine
pretty big numbers I'm like oh yeah I'm
gonna get this money but I don't I don't
really know what I did to deserve it but
I'm thankful for it at least
especially now that I went through the
competition last week announced a
competition for shout outs to a bunch of
channels and III don't know I went
through them all and I'm like
these are pretty good and I don't know
it made me feel even more lucky to to be
where I am to have such a huge
opportunity of this channel to be so
like I don't know like I guess it's it's
it's weird for me it's something new for
me you brothers really haven't made my
dreams come true over the last year at
the very least so can't thank you enough
for us yeah I will make a montage video
I promise it's crazy I have it I have
I'm the last one I made made we had
800,000 subscribers and now we ride like
2 million so I think it's about freakin
time I made one
the thing is I'm uploading more videos
now and that means a lot more work for
me so whenever I had time left extra
from editing I really don't want to sit
down and edit some more and so yeah
that's the only reason why I haven't
done one oh yeah the winners of the
competition I forgot there was 600
channels I went through by the way it
was crazy I was I gotta say I was really
impressed by a lot of channels even
though I didn't pick you I still really
enjoyed a lot of content and
you know I think so many of you have
potentials to be where I am so you know
keep doin what you doing
all right so the first one I choose was
um unusual subject this channel is funny
he made reviews thankfully add it in and
I have enough chill out I liked it
now if you hear the term rapping dog
what comes to mind can you be my dad an
actual dog so as I said the second one
is probably my favorite he was called
Tucker he made simulation let's play
some stupid simulation games and it was
funny and it's something I haven't seen
before I think a couple do it though but
he even made a nice twist on it and I
enjoyed it it was pretty cold you hold
down the right mouse and move the mouse
you can look around the operating
theatre wow look at that
oh you're right damn girl name next one
is to one there one to fear it's neither
real name they made minecraft machinima
I guess it was funny well made I really
enjoyed it
[Music]
music wave mein like really sweet music
songs remixes and it makes apparently
three every week I thought they were
pretty cold
[Music]
and daily new pure I don't remember why
I choose them but I just didn't get
ready wait I don't want my head going in
the same pocket as his no give me a
queen basket
get me a clean [ __ ] bones out I'm
gonna subtitle back cuz I don't even
know what the [ __ ] you just say I don't
all right so that was five or six one
two I was five I know you're some of the
competition congratulations I'll leave
their links in the description you can
go check them out and subscribe if you
want again this was I made this
composition and I always make them in
hopes that people will stop
self-advertising in my videos but they
never do it anyway so what the hell are
you gonna do again all competitions have
winners and losers and I'm sorry
don't blame me okay now I want to give a
shout out to my longtime bros out there
because I know there's a lot of pros
have been sticking around with me for a
while and I do appreciate it even though
I love all my brothers equally so anyway
that I think that was pretty much it for
me Bruce I'm gonna keep making videos as
long as you brothers on me so I this has
been by far the best year of my life and
I owe it all to you Bruce
two million let's go for three I don't
know
[Music]
I can't think you know for your support
bras and like I said it without you I
wouldn't be doing this so you ready for
2 million brofist there should be 2
million brothers doing this right now
all right again thanks for all your
support bras you know
[Music]